[MUSIC PLAY]
ANTHONY SULLIVAN: Mobile devices are extremely important to us
by "The Guardian".
That's why mobile devices are our future.
Like many publishers, we see a huge transition
heard from our mobile platforms.
In fact, we see our program users
Consume significantly more content than any of us
other users.
Clearly, Android is a very large part of it.
TOM GRINSTED: We're not exaggerating
if we say program users, including our Android users,
are our most valuable users across the portfolio.
They read more about our content.
They linger longer and spend more time with us.
Program users are between 10 and 20 times
more involved than the average web user.
Device-specific programs like our Android application provide features
you can't find on the mobile web.
And indeed, it is due to key issues
like always being present.
The fact that once you are on the device, you are always there
and your device stays on - this gives us opportunities
we never had before.
For example, if you look at your Android web integration,
in fact, it is about enabling people
to "Guardian" notifications at a much more timely and
receive interesting way.
And then to read it or save it immediately
until later when they see a story that is really important to them,
but they are in a situation where they can't really read it.
I'm really proud of the team here,
and have a subscription acceptance rate of over 90%.
So less than 10% of people choose
not getting our notifications.
And it really speaks of the quality of
editorial choices we make about it.
With such a great audience for our programs,
personalization is becoming increasingly important.
You can personalize your homepage.
And this is a very, very powerful feature.
This allows users to choose any kind of content
from across the network.
So it can be your favorite topic,
it can be your favorite author.
And we want to make sure the content is relevant to them
really prominent in their experience.
ANTHONY SULLIVAN: Getting users involved is of the utmost importance.
In fact, in many respects it is more important than simply being
have a large number of users for "The Guardian".
And to establish a habit is very important to us.
So it doesn't just help us with monetization,
but also for that right, almost lifelong relationship, with the audience
to build.
TOM GRINSTED: As a business we believe with our whole heart
that is the only way to be confident about the products we have
is going to launch is to test them, test them and test them again--
and exposing them to as many real readers as possible and real
users.
We do this through Google Play, by responding to reviews.
We do this through the Android beta program.
The reason we do all these things,
is because we really want to understand
what they do with our products.
And what they find difficult,
and they love a lot.
That kind of feedback helps us make strategic decisions
about what is most important to our readers
when they use the program.
A good example is the new Search that we are currently releasing.
This is a direct response to feedback
what we like about our beta program as well as on Google Play
got it.
Mobile devices on Android have played a key role in us
growth strategy in emerging markets
as well as in established markets.
Looking at our new markets -
India really a good example-- there
people are going directly to mobile devices.
And Android is a big part of it.
Our work on Android is therefore part of our international growth.